字幕: Moe Serizawa
校正: Hiroko Kawano
僕が今日お伝えしたいのは １個だけです
行動すれば 救える命がある
「行動すれば救える命がある」
って今言いましたけど
行動は自分で選ぶことができます
目の色や 肌の色や
才能や
もしかしたら
生まれる長さも 生きられる長さも
決まってるのかもしれない
だけど やるかやらないか
行動するかしないか
それだけは 自分で選ぶ —
行動すれば救える命がある
それを僕は今日話したいと思います
で 僕 行動すれば救える命がある
と言いましたけど
別に そんな昔から
行動できる人間じゃなかったんです
大学１年生のときに
日本医科大学という
医学部に入って一浪しました
で 医学部って特に 別に何も学ばないです
医学を学ばないです １年目は
で ダラダラしてて
コンパとかバイトとかそういうことを
まあ普通の大学生と同じようにしてて
なんかモヤモヤしてたんです
何かこう 自分の人生が
変わるきっかけを探してて —
で 僕の人生を変えたのは
この一枚の偶然のパンフレットでした
20歳のときにこのパンフレットを見て
渋谷の郵便局で 偶然
このパンフレットを見つけました
僕は振込で行っただけだったんですけど
150万円あれば
カンボジアに小学校が建ちます
150万集めて小学校が建てば
子供が笑顔になってくれるんだと
当時は考えて なんだかワクワクして
大学２年生のときに カンボジアに
小学校の視察に行きました
[通訳のブティさんとの出会い]
で 僕の人生の中で
カンボジアとの出会いがすごく多くて
ブティさんとの出会いも大きかったんですけど
ブティさん — 通訳のね
カンボジアは「ポルポトの大虐殺」という
クメール・ルージュの代表の
ポル・ポトという方が
1970年代に 200万人から
虐殺したと言われていて
３分の１から４分の１が
殺されたと言われています
知識層を中心に殺されて —
教師とか医者とか弁護士さんとか
カンボジアのプノンペンには
トゥール・スレン虐殺博物館ってのがあります
２万人収容されて 生き残ったのが７人
これは 拷問所です
亡くなった方の写真が 虐殺博物館にはあって
一枚一枚 展示されてます
もうこれ 全員亡くなった方ですけど
僕はこれを20歳のときに見て
なんか 適当に生きてる暇って
ないんだなって思ったんですよ
飛行機で８時間行った所で
当時2005年で 30年ぐらい違えば
彼と一緒のような運命だったかもしれなくて
僕は 適当に生きてきたんですよ
特に苦労もせず
医学部に入りたいと入って
だけど 生きたくても
生きられなかった人がいます
言い訳したいときって 沢山たぶんあって
今 NPOしてますけど
NPOの運営の仕方とか
赤ちゃんの命を救う方法とか
本の書き方とか 分かんないときがあります
だけど —
生きたくても 生きられなかった人がいます
死にたくなかったけど
生きられなかった人がいます
言い訳なんて 沢山したいんです
自分には才能がないとか
自分にはあれがないとか — だけど —
その人の苦しみに比べたら
たぶん 言い訳できないんです
なんか 曲がった背中が
まっすぐになったような気がして
行動してみようと思ったんです このとき
で 僕はカンボジアに
小学校を2005年に作りました
そしてそれから 継続支援を続けました
その小学校を建てたストーリーは
2011年に向井理さん、松坂桃李さん、
窪田正孝さん、柄本佑さんで映画になって
僕役は向井さんが演じてくれています
で [本が]10万部売れて
僕はちやほやされたんです
女の子にモテたり
メディアに出て有名人みたいになったり
で 2005年に小学校を建設してから
継続支援をしてたんですけど
2014年に 生後22日目の赤ちゃんを
亡くしたお母さんと出会います
自分が映画になって ちやほやされてる一方で
亡くなってる方がいました
で 僕はなんでこの人に対して
何かやりたいと思ったかっていうと
泣いてたんですよ このお母さん
で 生後３ヶ月未満の赤ちゃんは
基本的にお母さんの免疫で
感染症があっても闘えます
だから生後22日目で熱が出るっていうのは
すごくおかしいことなんです
生後21日目で熱が出て
だんだんだんだん呼吸が速くなったんです
熱が出て 呼吸が[速くなって]
ミルクを飲めなくなった
で カンボジアにも
なんて言うんですかね
医療保険が少しあるんですけど
彼女は入れなくて
バイクタクシーっていう
救急車みたいなのがあるんですけど
それを呼べなかったんです
10ドルかかるから 彼女は呼べなくて
で いよいよ赤ちゃんが
動かなくなったときに
借金をして 10ドルを借りて
病院に向かったんです
で 病院に向かうバイクタクシーの中で
もう亡くなってたんですよ
つまり遺体を抱えて行ったら
現地のお医者さんが
「もうこれ亡くなってます」と言って
遺体を抱えて 帰って
近くの土に
埋めました
で この話をするときに
お母さんは めちゃくちゃ泣いてました
人の幸せなんか 分かりませんよ
人の不幸なんて分かりません
何が不幸か幸せなのか僕には分からない
だけど —
虐待とかあるかもしれない
全世界のお母さんに会ったことはない 僕は
色んな人と話をしたわけでもない
だけど僕 １つ思うのは
自分の子供を失って
全く悲しくないお母さんは
世界中にきっといません
やっぱり泣いてる人を見てそう思って —
これ 現地のバイクタクシーです —
赤ちゃんはどうすれば助かっただろうか
当時分からなかったんですけど
それを学びに行きました
長崎の大学の熱帯医学研修課程
っていうのがあるんですけど
どうやったら赤ちゃんを救えるか
５歳未満の死亡率は
とっても良くなりました
赤いところは
1000人生まれたら 200人亡くなってました
つまり５人生まれて
１人が亡くなってる時代があったんです
2000年
このオレンジのところが
1000人生まれたら 100〜199人亡くなってます
これが 15年でどうなったかっていうと
赤い文字が消えました
1000人生まれて 200人以上亡くなる国が
もう世界でなくなった
５歳未満の死亡率の原因は
肺炎、下痢、マラリア
肺炎には 抗生剤があって
下痢には 「ORS」っていう
経口補水液があって
マラリアには 診断キットがあって
すごく世界はよくなった ５歳未満は
だけど 新生児といわれる
生後28日目の赤ちゃん[の死亡率]が
３〜４割しかまだ減ってません
いつ亡くなってるかっていうと
生まれた当日に亡くなります
生まれた当日に100万人亡くなります
そして生まれた１週間の死亡リスクが高い
で 今日の僕の講演を全部忘れていいです
１個だけ覚えて帰ってください
赤ちゃんの命は 救えます
すごく基本的なサービスで救える
家族計画、妊婦健診、助産師さん
出生直後の母乳哺育、薬剤投与の蚊帳
予防接種、ビタミンA
これ 医者いりません
医者がいらなくて
何十万人も救える命がまだある
もう理論的に分かってるんですよ
[自分に何ができるだろう？]
行動すれば 救える命があるんです
基本的な医療を整えるために
ワールド・ビジョンさんとお話をして
カンボジアの病院建設を迎えました
カンボジアは 母子保健が
すごく成功している国で
５歳未満とか乳児死亡は
すごく良くなっています
だけど 都市部と田舎の方では
まだ乳児死亡率も３倍ぐらいの差があります
で タイの国境沿い シェムリアップ —
アンコールワットで有名ですけど —
左上のタイの国境沿いの
バンティ・ミエンチャイという
ところに建設しました
で これは「伝統的産婆」っていわれてですね
助産師さんではない危険な分娩が
残っていたりする地域で
で かなり洪水が起こる地域なので
そこにそもそもアクセスできなかったりとか
アクセスしても
病院として機能しなかったら問題なので
基盤も整えて 基礎を整えて
病院を建設しました
僕が社会人になって学んだことは
誰かと協働することです
クラウドファンディングとして
500万円のご支援をいただいて
本当にありがたかったんですけど
沢山の人と協力して
カンボジアへの支援を行いました
そして昨年２月に
カンボジアに病院が建ちました
これが 開院式の様子
現地の厚生省の副大臣が来てくれました
新生児の先生と一緒にですね
小児科の先生と一緒に
赤ちゃんの命を救う技術も教えました
そして結果どうなったかっていうと
外来の患者さんは1000人ぐらい増えて
分娩数は２倍ぐらいになって
妊婦健診の数も増えて
予防接種の数も増えました
そして 泣いていたお母さんは
新しい男の子の命を授かって
男の子を産みました
このお父さんは
すごいぶっきらぼうな人なんですよ
僕と話すと こんな笑顔してくれないんです
やっぱり すごい嬉しそうな表情をしていて
赤ちゃんって
色んな人を笑顔にしてくれるんですよ
いまだに赤ちゃんが生まれて
救える命が 今もまだあります
この病院はもちろん機能してます
で 赤ちゃんが生まれるということは
どういうことでしょうか？
日本では１年間に何人の赤ちゃんが
生まれているでしょう？
だいたい１年間に
95万人の赤ちゃんが生まれてます
日本では１年間に
何人の赤ちゃんが亡くなってるか？
日本は新生児の死亡率が
世界トップクラスです
1000人生まれて １人も亡くならない国です
SDGsの目標値があるんですけど
それも 戦後20年ちょっとで達成してます
ものすごい 僕と
おじいちゃんとかおばあちゃん
親父世代が頑張ってくれて
医療者が僻地でも ものすごい汗水を流して
助産師さんがいて
だからこそ僕らが生まれて今 生きてて
そんな先輩方の尽力のおかげで
この数値が成り立ってます
日本は 最も安全な国の一つです
そして 世界で見ると
１歳未満の赤ちゃんは
まだ260万人亡くなっていて
100万人の赤ちゃんが
生まれたその日に亡くなってます
つまりそれは
日本で生まれる１年間の命が95万人なので
その１年間よりも多くの赤ちゃんの命が
生まれたその当日に 亡くなってます
で 一番伝えたいことはこれです
その生まれた当日に亡くなってる —
日本の１年間よりも亡くなっている命は
基本的な医療サービスさえあれば
確実に救える赤ちゃんの命が
まだ世界にあります
良くはなってますけど まだ足りてません
なんで 行動するのか と
なぜ行動し続けるか 理由は僕は１つだけ —
出会った人が泣いてたからです
アフリカのどっかの誰かが死んでたとしても
僕は明日何もしないかもしれない
中東のどっかで誰かが
レイプされて殺されてても
何もしないかもしれないです
だけど出会った人は「あの人」になったんです
「誰か」じゃなくて「あの人」なんです
そしてそれが行動さえすれば救える
だからもし 辛くてやめそうになったら
思い出してください
「誰か」じゃなくて
「あの人」のために行動してください
そしてあなたが行動することで
救える命があって 笑顔があります
もしそれで 行動をやめそうになったら
自分は何のために行動してるのか
誰にどんな笑顔をやりたかったのか
それだけ思い出してください
それがたぶん
行動を続けられる秘訣のような気がします
大事なんでもう１回言います
行動すれば救える命があります あなたが
そして 行動さえすれば
笑顔にできる人がいます
そして 行動して辛くなったら
思い出してください
あなたは誰を、どんな人を、何のために
なぜ、笑顔にしたかったのか
医者になって 難しいことは沢山覚えたけど
そんなの後から身につきます
難しいことなんて
行動して 挫けたら思い出してください
誰のために 何をしたかったのか
それを僕は忘れないで
一生かけて頑張っていきたいと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）